[Music]
we have tons of exciting new features in
the 1.7 update and we've added a great
deal of challenge for you and your team
in 1.7 the agents of pushback the
factions and are doing all they can to
keep New York safe they'll have to be
creative and agile in order to face the
unexpected threats coming up
with global events we're adding
challenges with big rewards such as
classified gear sets and vanity items
we've added two types of modifiers
firstly the global modifier which will
affect everywhere in the map this will
change the way that the players approach
the game and make it more fun and make
them more efficient at killing enemies
we've also added activity modifiers
these make things a little bit more
difficult for the player but the rewards
be worth the charge the first global
event is outbreak there'll be more
global events but we winch for them just
yet as a reward for pushing back the
unexpected threats shade has begun
reworking your favourite gear sets we
call them classified gear these new
classified gear sets have better primary
stat roles new recalibration options and
new 5 and 6 piece set bonuses upon
completing global events you'll be able
to show off your achievements by wearing
our new face masks which can be found in
the leaderboard or in our commendations
over a year
our players an accomplished my amazing
feats but we want to give you some even
greater challenges and some great
rewards we want to allow you to show up
visually the accomplishments that you're
most proud of
now there are variety of our patches for
you to unlock by completing
commendations of varying difficulty kill
100 enemies with the shotgun complete
napalm production site and legendary
mode activate all 63 EKKO seasons and so
many more we've listened to your calls
and now we can reach us tamai your face
however you want it you can finally get
rid of your sunglasses or change your
haircut
we've also added encrypt of caches
containing exclusive emotes outfits and
skins these encrypted caches can be
unlocked with keys that you find in the
world or via cleaning credits we can't
wait to find out who will be the first
to complete all the commendations join
us for the first global event outbreak
and we hope that you will enjoy these
new features and reward yourself
aggressively see you in Manhattan
[Music]
[Music]